[Musique]
bonjour music expo muni de ce nouveau
culture première fabrice ramaye le
trépidant leader et chanteur de destins
malo garde à la clé pour avril un
sixième album avec un titre m'a gâché un
concert demain à 20 heures à sainte
marie pour l'instant il n'est pas encore
arrivé on espère le voir autres
musiciens autre univers celui de vincent
corvec de retour d'un une musique une
musique qui sort de l'habituel une
musique planante qui rappellent des
groupes mythiques des années 80-90 de la
peinture avec de la présidente de l'udar
union des artistes de la réunion avec
sabine tyrrell
il sera question de l'exposition 350 ans
de la nomination de la rivière saint
denis
tout un programme jean-paul mais l'adq
culture première sur réunion 1ère
bonjour vincent corvec
bonjour vous êtes né en bretagne vous
avez grandir la réunion vous êtes auteur
compositeur interprète et proposer de la
musique électronique instrumentale ou
chantés en français ou en anglais
vous vous produisez en solo ou
accompagné par exemple avec la chanteuse
marie lanfroy on connaît puisqu'elle
chante dans notre groupe où le vidéaste
pierre moulin exemple
[Musique]
où
on
je
[Musique]
derrière
d'user ouf
ce n'est rien
[Musique]
si vous
m
puis vous
thériault
l'amour n'est rien
[Musique]
si on a
matin
[Musique]
où
derrière
thériault
[Musique]
à
on
d'amours derrière
matériaux
m
jeudi sur votre site vincent corvec
contemplative et onirique
la musique de vincent corvec et la bande
originale d'une vie intérieure
voilà le tableau dressé personnellement
le mot onirique me convient parfaitement
moi ça me rappelle des années 90 thank
your engine kraftwerk vous connaissez
oui je connais bien alors vous en
inspirer
je pense que j'étais peut-être un peu
trop jeune pour m'ont inspiré jeu
peut-être que si on fait référence aux
années 90 ça serait plutôt portishead
des groupes de trip hop anglais ouais on
verra justement qu'est ce qui vous
inspire quel score généralement on
classifie les gens ont aimé dans des
crocs mais ils sont comme ci comme ça
vous vous classez quelque part ou alors
vous êtes inclassable je me classe là où
on classe moi je ne réfléchis pas
manière intellectuelle et
en catégorie je fais ce qui me vient
donc si on veut dire de moi que je fais
de la musique contemplative pourquoi pas
si on trouve ça trop onirique pourquoi
pas je ne la définit pas qu'est ce que
vous a donné envie de faire ce genre de
musique c'est comme ça c'est vu comme ça
parce que vous aimez les claviers je
pense que ce mois-ci saljic
celles qui correspondent plus à mon
caractère je suis assez calme et j'aime
bien dormir donc je lis onirique
voilà je suis ça aurait été quelqu'un
d'énervé ou de de colérique j'aurais
peut-être fait du musique différente
alors êtes vous avez aussi un parcours
qui n'est pas vous n'êtes pas de
musiciens comme ça tout de suite c'est
bon racontez-nous qu'on se sait j'ai
commencé la musique à 15 ans de manière
complètement autodidacte avec quatre
amis on a acheté une boîte à rythmes
c'était dans les années 90 c'est vers la
mode c'était à la mode et c'est surtout
ce qui coûte le moins cher parce qu'on
voulait faire de la musique on voulait
faire du hip hop mais on ne voulait pas
chanter sur des vinyles déjà existants
ce qui se faisait à l'époque c'est qu'on
achète des vignes et instrumentaux et
qu'on chantait par dessus non voulait
faire notre propre musique et on ne
savait ni jouer de batterie ni guitare
ni de basse donc ont acheté une boîte à
rythme avec nos économies de noël de
l'époque on se la passer une semaine à
tour de rôle donc on avait en gros une
semaine tous les cinq semaines cette
machine j'ai commencé comme ça et puis
ensuite il ya quelques concerts le
groupe s'est un peu s'est dissout et
j'ai continué en solo alors je lis
musicien autodidacte serment partie vrai
et faux puisque bon certes vous avez
commencé comme ça mais après vous vous
êtes formés oui mais à trente trois ans
et alors ça faisait déjà depuis que
j'avais 15 ans mais c'est un bel âge 33
ans est un très bel âge h christique
pour composer des choses qu'ils pensent
qu'ils font planer voilà cet âge là j'ai
commencéà
m'intéressait la musique instrumentale
et classique
enfin davantage je me suis dit qu entre
au conservatoire ça pouvait être
intéressant pour comprendre le langage
de ces instruments et alors donc vous
avez choisi d'instruments que le
casselois particulier vous où vous jouez
au joaillier de noms de plusieurs
instruments et vous avez fait un choix
je jouais déjà du piano chez moi et je
me suis dit que c'était pas mal
d'aborder sa part le côté arrangements
c'est à dire intégrer les classes
d'arrangement du conservatoire qui
couvre l'ensemble de l' orchestre
l'ensemble de
des cordes des instruments à vent des
percussions pour avoir une vision
globale de ce que je voulais faire
alors je dis à l'endroit de ce minéral
qui est avec nous que si elle veut poser
des questions verse encore vois que vous
pouvez vous pouvez le faire ça va
s'exprimer s'exprime bien si vous
connaissez la musique et si vous voulez
gagner pas soumises y découvrir alors
aujourd'hui vincent corvée que vous êtes
tout seul ou presque tout seul ça
correspond justement pourquoi car à
coeur c'est à dire vous aimez travaillez
votre paix intérieure sans avoir sans
être dérangé
oui peut-être qu'il ya des caractères
qui font que on a besoin d'être en
groupe dans une dynamique et une sorte
d'émulation comme ça moi j'aime bien
travailler seul
c'est moins de contraintes et pourtant
de temps en temps vous êtes accompagné
sur sun mal à canteleu en fonction du
contexte
voilà quand c'est possible que j'aime
bien trop accompagnés par les bonnes
personnes sur scène c'est agréable
c'est quoi c'est qui les bonnes
personnes les bonnes personnes c'est
surtout d
des gens avec qui je m'entends bien déjà
par ailleurs dans la vie en dehors de la
musique et des gens qui sont là pour des
choses vraiment
justifier quoi pas pour faire du
décoration c'est à dire des gens qui
sont vraiment du milieu ça venant des
gens qui ont qui apporte quelque chose
de vraiment personnel c'est à dire
qu'ils sont pas interchangeables marie
lanfroy par exemple a une voix très
particulière qui fait qu'elle n'est pas
interchangeable dans un groupe un duo ou
même si elle est choriste ou quand
commence et j'allais dire on va vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'était l'année où
vous avez vous fait votre premier
concert à caen j'avais c'était le 21
juin de 1996 j'avais 16 ans vous en
souvenez bien oui c'était dans la
cafétéria d'un intermarché
c'était très très réussie aux femmes
enceintes en métropole en bretagne est
d'accord voir si vous avez d'autres
expériences comme celle là oui après en
trois solitaires en 2003 j'ai sorti un
premier album sur un label à nantes
ce qui m'a permis de faire des premières
parties et beaucoup de festivals à
l'époque des premières parties de
groupes de l'époque
mickey 3d d'herning spears ce qui
tournait à l'époque dans les festivals
quoi et en 2007 un album à l'ombre sur
un label anglais alors c'est marrant
quand même votre parcours parce que vous
grandissez ici vous vous mettez à la
musique donc conservatoire mais vous
avez aussi les premiers concerts se font
en français alors que l'on aurait pu
croire que il aurait pu se faire ici à
la réunion puisque je vais beaucoup
d'allers retours du passé je pense la
moitié de ma vie là-bas la moitié de ma
vie ici je la passe la moitié de l'année
là-bas la moitié de l'année ici vous
allez on était là-bas et on y revenez si
c'est ça voilà la bretagne où manquent
tant que ça parfois et quand j'en ai
marre je repars à la réunion mais c'est
bien de pouvoir faire que le va et vient
comme ça quand on a envie pour peut vous
demander dans la vie vous fait quoi de
la musique uniquement
adacore pensais que vous étiez
enseignants quelque chose comme ça à
côté c'est bien de vous en vous en vivez
alors dont vous vous produisez aussi à
la réunion qui vous a remarqué et c'est
la raison qui vous a appelé en premier
c'est pascal montrouge du théâtre de
champ fleuri d'accords clairs c'est lui
qui nous a donné en 2001 2013 en 2013
vous été surpris ou bouzid est content
ah j'étais très content pour vous y
attendiez ou parce que pour que parfois
comme cdd des stands et des rencontres
ou des choses qui font que ben voilà ça
ça ça comme ce qui est étonnant c'est
que ce soit la plus grosse structure qui
nous propose de
de faire deux soirées une au théâtre
chant que rino théâtre plein air et je
dise tout simplement on essaye on vous
fait confiance si ça marche tant mieux
ça marche pas moment on aura essayé vous
savez vous avez beaucoup de chance parce
que des tas de musiciens et le nez qui
se battent pour faire chauffer le rire
ah oui et qui ne pompe à champ fleuri et
qui justement ont envie de faire ch en
floride parce que bon c'est vrai pas
c'est la révélation de l'an passé c'est
un passage à les dire presque
incontournable à orphée champ fleuri et
mourir je dirais mais c'est presque ça
ce qui est compliqué c'est qu'on a
commencé par ça donc après
faire autre chose vous voulez dire faire
mieux bah ouais et alors vous êtes
arrivé à faire mieux on à fait différent
à vous êtes allé quand même au printemps
de bourges et vous avez été sélectionné
présélection alors présélection alors
dans ce cas on a joué on revient d'une
tournée indienne par exemple ça c'était
intéressant par des envois en paraît
avoir parlé on parle pas de deux ans
maintenant
donc vous avez fait c'est l'ex originale
des inuits du printemps de bourges live
au festival est trop electropicales par
bong festival de bridge à maurice
livevault palaxa pouvait apporter duo
avec deux présidents lukasz santala je
connais pas mais bon pas c'est superbe
et la musique comme vous non c'est plus
eux c'est un mélange entre eux de la pop
et de la bonne musique chanter un
brésilien c'est très beau alors je
continue 2016 live au festival sakifo
you man u européenne des musées
kabardock mais la partie de radio elvis
le cas première partie de chapelier fou
pour ça veut dire qu'on vous fait
confiance
oui et ça ça vous plaît beaucoup ont
fait peu de concerts en fait si on
regarde bien ça fait deux trois concerts
par an mais on va vous payez pas ah non
là je me plains de concert pour faire un
choix
bon alors vous avez de la chance parce
que vous avez à boussera mike vient
d'arriver lui aussi j'suis pas si koné
l'inde madagascar je suis sûr qu'il
connaît alors rapproché fabrication la
peur la notion connaît bon d'accord
alors des fois que je passe de prendre
les missions en cours mais écoute que ça
vincent corfec qui fait quand ils savent
en elle
[Musique]
m
ans
[Musique]
alors ce genre de musique c'est à dire
ni pourquoi parce que vous avez envie
d'avoir une expérience un diane et
doublure présenter votre musique et leur
dire voilà ce que je fais moi est ce que
nous on peut s'entendre
ouais en fait on va jouer al yawm à
l'année dernière au mois de mai il y
avait un tourneur indien qui était là la
musique qu'on a proposé lui a plu donc
on a organisé une tournée ensemble on
est parti là bas
début mars pour huit concerts dans
quatre villes différentes lesquels on
marque deux concerts à mumbai de à
bangalore chennai aussi non à chennai
bangalore new delhi et pune une ville
étudiante dans le sud de bombay perd
l'accueil du public casey parce que
quand même il écouta peut pas tout le
monde mais la micro majorité écoutent de
la musique traditionnelle
en fait ce que j'ai découvert sur place
c'est qu'il y assure un milliard
de la population il ya quand même une
classe moyenne qui a
entre 20 et 40 ans on va dire une classe
moyenne qui sort qui des références
occidentales entend de la musique qu'ils
consomment et qui vit la musique de la
même façon que nous donc en fait c'est
ça la vouliez atteindre mais je savais
même pas qu'elle existait en fait et on
a découvert que laisser les salles de
concert et la dette est plein et qu'il y
avait des gens très motivés et qu'ils
venaient nous parler ensuite on me
donnait en des références leonard cohen
massive attack fin qui nous parlait de
ça il vous parlez pas de destin malaga
celui là qui est en face
moi j'ai excusez moi je voulais sentent
bien et alors au niveau album il ya un
album c'est bien être c'est ça que vous
trouvez ça moi je n'ai rien pour
l'instant ils savent ce qu'est ce que
j'ai vu sur je vous ai envoyé des pré
écoute peut-être non non non moi j'ai vu
sur deezer j'ai vu quelque chose oui ce
sont ce sont des pré écoute pour
professionnels d'accord de l'album
histoires d'objets j'ai eu droit alors
voilà bien il y en a en novembre 2010
cette première sortie
on va demander en attendant fabrice de
sortir son accordéon s'il n'a pas oublié
il a oublié d'en bâtir été accordés en
voilà et donc leur alors cet album il
aura combien de titres dessus il
s'appelle comment il va sortir quand
vincent
vous savez pas si si je sais mais je ne
vous dis pas à vous êtes un petit coquin
pad pas de source pas de scoop pour nous
qui pensions avoir un scoop pour cette
émission n'aura pas d'envoi on peut
quand même écouter un morceau de 2018
alors bien naître quelques années on a
un côté l'aja non non non pas d'excusés
mais on a écouté quelque chose tout à
l'heure qui est extrêmement n'est rien
l'amour ligne alors voila ca exclusivité
il sera dans l'album black et son album
verte et puis quand vous écoutez là ça
passe saga rome pour ça fait un peu pub
et et non en fait c'est que marie
lanfroy justement la chanteuse de
saudade organise une exposition de ses
photographies à la saga du rhum d'accord
et vous avez composé pour elle et elle
m'a demandé de faire l'habillage sonore
de la capac titre alors pour l'instant
l'hépatite à dax et parce que c'est moi
j'ai vu ça garonne dont je suis dit
c'est simple soit on part tous les cas
merci d'être venus et puis on écoute un
petit extrait donc de cet habillage
sonore et après on passe à l'autre
musicien
[Musique]
culture première avec jean-paul menad
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
bonjour fabrice rama yade et bien merci
alors fabrice travaille pour ça qu'il
n'aurait pas reconnu dimanche rappelle
comment fabrice lhomme il peut dire en
malgache diable ou les piles et plus
donc ça ces morceaux traditionnels ou
l'inde est l'un des bonnes chansons
assez connu là bas mais rama pas mal
d'atouts glados la famille lorsque la
loi famille dans les grands mais après
midi aussi ce mélange là mon côté malgas
et papa côté indien bjp fait la réunion
où il se fait petit mélange là et il
craint vraiment grammont et les mais
c'est benoît pas trop ça m'amuse à bas
prix la réunion ni même la nuit et nous
les mélanger à nous les n'aurait pas un
impact plus saine que l'autre nous
venions nous les tout ou presque tout
comme d'inamuddin n'est pas rien
caméléon new delhi transforme à nouveau
mis son fonds distincts brésilien non tu
es tu et l'afrique un prophète mais un
peu tout ça à la fabrice ramaré le
leader du groupe d ce thème à le gars
mais qui ne présente plus un nouvel
album qui sortent bientôt vive le roi
satam est important bravo bravo ksa de
même pardon en français c'est vive le
roi et le titre original cv long comme
monza k now
welten jacques annaud alain verna
bellounat on pense à la française et à
l'accord fernand la belle n'a pas encore
dix jours demain ena combien la commune
type de cela 13 sites notre site c'est
des mélanges au fait des séances un
mélange de de 20 ans que plus ou moins
nous et là à travers des échanges
financiers et cet album là on va dire
c'est comme si notre premier call home
on y écoute plus ou moins l'album il
retrouve à peu près 7000 à retrouver
dans les débuts de destin dans les
années
2007 vite et le style d'aujourd'hui ça
devienne un mélange à peu près de tours
radio contact des nouveaux enfants
william le nouveau enfants mais apple a
ou les autres c'est un peu celle ci
passant pas trop il ressort une parfois
c'est la famille couleurs parce que des
fois c'est un baume la mine où l' écoute
énormément le public énormément parce
que des fois des gens d'y faire des
critiques par exemple un exemple a déjà
dit ouais pourquoi mallevialle
énormément chanté par malgache
pourquoi ne pas chanter en indiens ou
américains et que se répande azote fait
et nous désole que en fin de compte à
nous nos bases si la base à l'origine
à l'origine le monde parle de l'inde au
point un petit exemple comment
passionnel map à l'impartition festival
chanel ne tricote pas ni en anglais ni
hadji donc je ne maîtrise pas un bouton
anglais
le wind corp a créé le bois imagine mal
un esclave département la réunion est
maintenant marbre comme ça chante une
chanson chantée dans mon langue
originale dans la langue que mikami pâle
mais ça papa le dit lui-même sa part
l'anglais donc me parle que le maloya
il a été créé par les africains par les
indiens et les malgaches c'est un
mélange de tout ça d'essayer dé ces mots
défend comprends pas ce qu'ils disent à
l'ancienne qu'un homme a voulu mataly ce
moment plus festif
un homme comme pour les gens qui
connaissent pas nous à la radio nous les
spectacles plus ou moins beaucoup de
chorégraphie oui ça il faut les voir
vous avez vu je vois son corps avec déjà
17 magasins mais madame tirez vous avez
vu déjà sur scène
il faut les voir à la première fois je
les ai vus j'ai été éblouie moelle à
l'entrée sur scène des dégâts de destins
maloya ça vaut le coup donc voilà c'est
c cnet manquons 22 de fabrique sa
chorégraphie chorégraphie et surtout et
c'est ce que justement c'est qu'il a
beaucoup beaucoup plus on aide le bas
par rapport aux festivaliers ce qui fait
beaucoup de danse et à nos garçons tels
effets des chorégraphies l'état quant à
l'appareil sera même la face on sait où
le roi cas façon ou la bible habillé
comme un roi ou en tous les cas c'est le
disque à regarder
c'est lula billet ou se retrouvent tout
ça au fait c'est dans l'imagination
l'imagination ou c ou quittez votre
micro qui minait preuve matérielle que
l'intrus qui date de 15 ans que des
petits métiers dessine enfin carré rouge
le carré bleu marine et monte at-il
ajouté il m'a dit tu es au fait mieux ce
linge de lit de la falaise et c'est
sarkozy indien dans ce mélange de tout
notre peuple à des armes à deux lampées
dire ça comme un grand chemise
oui comme un grand col mao ouais ouais
mais pour le truc que décorer
mais ces moyens dit il fait mater
carretera arrêté là et en
utilise dessus cela soit bien celle qui
connaît là soit on utilise la soie et la
couleur est plus ce niveau-là lumiel il
est vraiment attirant les pats match
comme tu
emmenés par transpiration et nous allons
les voir ils voient la salle et sur les
pas mates messieurs bon alors on ne peut
plus continuer nouvelle écoutant un
morceau donc de l'album à dire pourquoi
nous avons d'abord
[Musique]
en famille ben soul et la disco témoins
baho sigonella
veille six mois comme c'est me sente
présence écoute le daytona - fonctions
de maire
nikon est là aux cobayes six mois
où ça
[Musique]
vous déconnez là haut
oh pas ici moi
où les comme le voice aux côtés - il
fait pris seul à moi
la poupée
même la batterie
pompey monde elle apprend à lire
la finale est là où la finale et la all
un final
waouh et
martin aller
là où ça fait râler
c'est un morceau de salon c'est un
maloya sur des thèmes alias espèce de ce
lot m'a arrangé à la maloja roman un
roman ce roman un roman ce arrangé à la
sauce maloya mais il parle d'une
gramoune est mort mais surtout fait ma
peine ma grand-mère ya deux ans et c'est
une chanson qui parle pour moi comment a
dit si facebook
le mot ni la perte d'un être cher il va
reconnaître de cette chanson là parce
que des fois les mêmes si la paix ça n'a
pas été un an deux ans ou accepte
rarement la partie de cette personne et
nous nous dit dans la chanson que la vie
d'aujourd'hui montrent en parle de ma
grand-mère lévis au jour d'aujourd'hui
ça veut dire faites là le fait que nous
parle de libin z il allait vivre parce
qu'ici un mot nous parle du lilas immo
le temps qu'un moon hi fi nale ou parle
de libye l'idée encore vivants fait
alors justement shoot page facebook et
marquer les vraies paroles viennent de
la voix des ancêtres et vous guide et
que votre chemin vous savez la crise a
vu un vin quand rien ne peut vous
arrêter si vous croyez en vous et il ya
une grande différence à mes respects
comment il ya une grande différence
entre la transe total et la demie trans
d'accord alassane articule assez présent
dans le milieu qu'elle tombe à dire ah
oui vous mélangez 2 et séoul a marqué
pas moins annoncé après vous facebook
nous mais vous savez à droite à gauche -
deviennent spin offs et antiphrase que
nous là s'initialiser plutôt dans cosi
la transe
déjà quand nous en coller sur scène
musiciens qu'on laisse a vraiment porté
par musique ou faire mon dieu les gens
ils pensent que des jalons trans que des
forfaits des choses que mes roulés ou
les bat on va dire que moi
personnellement
on va dire à une période de l'année vie
et la plupart du temps si la scène ne
retire on peut parler de la semi 3 2003
a causé à 2030 mais où ça gramoune et la
kangoo les world chanter au fait on
ressent des présences c'est peut-être
simplicio naturel si dominique août à
moi mais au fait c'est comme si on a
cette sensation que la merci cela que
l'association connaît mantello cette loi
pas les offres qui compte mais on a
cette sensation que comme l espace
communal un sensationnel présence d'un
accordéon les plus forts parce que vous
faites parce que peut-être le fait que
nous nous chante les bains il vient
vraiment du kawaii il vient là me prends
un exemple il ya nous le répète avec un
musicien que les invités n'oubliera pas
dit c'est quoi comme musicien vous savez
de l'avion non bon d'accord ok ben en
fait le gars était toujours un art hogan
tout comme a bien noté pense qu'ils
étaient en transe dans la manière
localité pour la can enjoy it away
l'égalité son pied ça va vous parle la
transe vincent korvac ou pas
approchez-vous du micro s'il vous plaît
passant par les musiques fin qui est
beaucoup plus lente donc c'est une autre
sorte de transe plus proches de la
méditerranée limitation de cette fête la
plus sûre à plusieurs types de transport
5,0
c'est un dessin changer l'âge puisque la
transhumance est la première chose c'est
la méditation la trans'oise faut déjà
c'est une attitude samir el vous
connaissez d'estais maloya non je n'ai
pas moi je vous invite à vous regarder
ne serait-ce que les pochettes les
jaquettes puisque vous vous êtes peintre
je pense que ça va pas vous interpeller
mais ça peut vous plaire parce que c'est
vraiment c'est quelque chose de spécial
c'est très rouge jaune enfin il s'éteint
ces rutilants c'est voilà c'est
particulier bien eux
fabrice millions merci demain soit aux
jouets ou sa couleur
demain je vais sainte-marie salle du
parc à 21 défaites y croise en salle de
fête du pâté à sainte marie tanguay d
accueil pour les gens parlaient pas de
susciter des palais les écrase a fait un
bain si les gens peuvent venir venir
mais là ça pue la place un ennemi poèmes
sécurité aussi un faux panneaux offert
toutes les choses là étaient faits pour
eux
au fait la base du crois que la lironde
500 personnes la 450 d'accord quand tu
peux voir une petite marge mais a
reconnu à demi longtemps j -c la radio
dit longtemps geely va venir et 56 en ne
faisant vite pour que vive le roi du
titre de l'album
ceux qui devront passer ou non dans
l'interprétation que nous fait sur cette
chanson là c'est mon papa grand mère
grand père en fait - midi l'éducation
que big n est pas mon ses marraines
l'éducation que mon papa laden à -6 vous
d'aujourd'hui milices cumulés c'est
grâce à mon papa est aujourd'hui jour du
minadt le sens de mon grand-père de
malromé cole 2020 mais les fier de
représenter bana et moi marc griffin
chanson du banat au fait merci d'abm abu
dhabi group et à maman des grands mères
mais n'a voulu dit parce que aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui dans le monde que new line a
énormément de manque de respect envers
la part envers les plus vieux nous fait
comprendre les gens si les par les
parents n'étaient pas là des forêts par
an les prix varient pour ou et demain
matin
la big me mettre justement c'est parce
que menez enfants et nos enfants canada
money as à mon papa billets fier d'eux
donc lhi limmattal comme un roi et nous
n'avons du match ce petit côté là - pour
moi c'est mon papa grand-mère groupe est
sa comédie vive le roi mehdi comme s'il
dit vivement et moment je te marche en
tête monsieur scène et me dis vive papa
et maman grand-mère européen
tiens ça va même si côté look on
commence tremblay
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'avant droit donne la peine arrivé à
la bonne date avec une arrivée
athée
tiens ça bat maxi côté
[Musique]
on commence en b télé
hu à la base radio latina à la bonne
date à bettina à la bonne mini bonnafé
malouda mari nous a hélas ma gueule ou
ça m'a sauvé
il m'avait loser au match
[Musique]
la veille
[Applaudissements]
la page a4 marie 12 ans et la pana
thomas vie nous a hélas pas d'amis dans
nine alfano et dany boon dragana
made in usa et la fin de l'année machine
à l'ipo est bloqué il a dit dans la voix
cassée
[Musique]
et
danser
la danse
[Musique]
et
vacante et manawa temps
[Musique]
culture première avec jean-paul medad
ap ap les blues merci merci merci le roi
fabrice sabine tyrrell bonjour bonjour
vous êtes la nouvelle présidente de
l'uda l'union des artistes de la réunion
association créée en 1979 elle a donc
conduit tant que créer un par tony
manglou et un groupe d'artistes
indépendants peintres sculpteurs
plasticiens graveur etc et aujourd'hui
vous venez nous parler des 350 ans de la
nomination de la rivière de saint denis
alors d'abord comment se porte plus
d'art un leader se porte bien
il était à peine quand jachère l'arrêt
pendant quelques années on a eu des
petits problèmes donc de bureaux dans
des présidents dire qu'il y en a un qui
a été mutés en métropole note qui est
partie aux antilles
locke est décédé de conclusion elle
était en stand by pendant trois quatre
ans et on la reprise avec une équipe là
justement depuis 2014 et ça repart sur
les chapeaux de roue vous êtes mauvais
d'adhérents pour l'instant 60
sans compter les retardataires qui n'ont
pas encore payé leur adhésion 2017 bon
vous avez entendu on paye des
cotisations mais 60 c'est beaucoup c'est
peu ses moyens
c'est parti jusqu'à 160 alors donc on
reprend bien quoi parce qu'au départ on
était une vingtaine et les deux
premières années là ça vient je sens que
ça passe c'est parti alors pourquoi
avoir fait cette exposition donc 350 ans
de la nomination de la rivière saint
denis alland 350 ans c'est parce que ça
fait trois cent cinquante ans quand elle
porte ce nom c'est ça oui voilà en fait
il ya un bateau qui est arrivé au large
saint denis ça plaît il s'appelait saint
denis
non il s'appelait ça te dit voilà et il
s'est mis au large de dans la baie de
san libye libre choix et il y avait
c'était en 1667
donc il y avait pas de ville pas de
village et vais rien personne n'habite
est là et on a donné le nom de la
rivière lot n'a donné le nom du bateau à
la rivière et après quand la ville s'est
construite elle a pris le nom de la
rivière
c'est devenu cynique et nous on a voulu
commémorer cette cette action la cua
alors question pour vous allez voir pour
que je vous pose cette question est ce
que la petite île fait partie de saint
denis
bersani ou pas la petite île devrait
faire partie de la rivière bien sûr
puisque allée dans la vallée bien alors
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que je
suis à voir vos tableaux de l'exposition
qui commence donc demain c'est bien ça
jusqu'aux feux jusqu'au 28 avril rassure
les voies et il n'y a pas de petite île
maintenant il ya l'église de la voix de
loin on a pas on n'a pas vraiment
j'allais dire le lieu d'arrivée
chaque personne va dire ben y'a pas
l'edf au fond il n'ya pas le pont qui
traverse la rivière han guo il n'y a pas
là la vallée il n'ya pas il ya tellement
de représentation comme chipoter
rg pucci poté alors donc bien on a
essayé de représenter au mieux de toute
façon parce que les artistes ils sont
venus on a été vain pendant quatre
week-ends en bas de la rivière et on n'a
pas su en si tu qu'on n'a pas la rivière
l'embouchure il ya eu beaucoup il ya
beaucoup de tableaux sur l'embouchure
bas beaucoup d'avoir justement beaucoup
de tableaux son embouchure
éventuellement avec le cap bernad voilà
ils ont aimé le cap bernard aussi donc
il ya des maisons qui sont au fond que
j'avais jamais vu
quant à travers plongé comme ça vient le
collège non vers le col l'ancien collège
là il ya une maison que j'avais jamais
vu ici apparemment elle a été vendue
donc ils ont déboisé tout le tout le
village est maintenant c'est quoi cette
maison là parce que je la connais pas ce
que nous allons arriver oui je suis j'ai
toujours habité hassani j'ai toujours je
connais saint denis j'ai j'avais jamais
vu cette maison et c'est pour ça que moi
je les les pins dans fait alors vous
seulement vos si vous avez pas vous vous
avez pas vous surtout la rue du pont oui
la rue du pont pourquoi courir tout ça
parce que parce que ce gros bâtiment qui
a land là qui était à un moment un bon
avant c'était boutique chinois madame
chinois comme était petit à petit mais
avant vous étiez petit une maison comme
ça avec des gros qui a retardé pierre de
taille elle pouvait pas être qu'une
boutique chinois quand ça devait être un
magasin de l'argent des 1 c'est fort
possible puisque plus bas vous avez deux
des dépôts de rome
voilà donc et après vous aviez la
chocolaterie y ait de plus haut est tout
simplement pas dessiner on n'a pas pas
on n'avait pas suffisamment de temps
pour peindre tout la rivière saint-denis
et vous savez là il ya quand même 45
tableaux et oui exactement je les ai
comptés et figurez-vous qu'en face de
cette grande bâtisse que vous avez
peinture il y avait donc la boutique
albac sellal bac et musiciens aussi qu'
aujourd'hui à la retraite et de la côte
et la boutique au une personne n'a pas
abouti qu ils cliquent pourtant paul et
les gens qui habitent de la rivière san
et la boutique aux usa là c'était un
monument incontournable aussi bien en
fait on a demandé aux gens de la rivière
saint denis si vous voulez venir peindre
avec nous ma hésité un peu intimidé pas
assez sûrs d'eux pour venir venir avec
nous quoi moi j'aurais bien aimé j'avais
essayé au départ personne
des tableaux à l'acrylique c'est sacré
d'iqaluit
il ya aussi du pastel mais on n'a pas le
sculpteur n'a pas pu venir parce qu'ils
savaient pas quoi représenter parce
qu'on a à plusieurs sculpteurs dans
l'association aussi mais il se demander
quoi représenter la cua c'est pas une
pêcheuse de biche et que peut-être
georges ans rien une femme - pêcheurs de
bichiques il n'a pas été inspiré par les
lieux apparemment ben en fait ils se
sont pas sentis le courage de venir
peindre au dd venir de tailler sur place
quoi parce qu'en fait le loge à napier
le challenge c'était de venir en bas de
la rivière pendant quatre week-ends de
créer l'oeuvre qui allaitent exposées
dans la mairie de saint denis parce que
donc on est dans l'ancien hôtel de ville
à l'étagé la salle d'exposition et il
fallait créer l'oeuvre pour l'amener là
et ils se sentent et peut-être pas tous
eu suffisamment prêt à créer une oeuvre
qui allait pas être prête les mois
suivants quoi vous étiez où exactement
physiquement pour peindre à calandre et
on était dans le parking à l'entrée
juste près de la loi l'embouchure
justement des dons vers l'embouchure
vers l'a senti corniche quoi ok oui
c'est pour ça vous avez peint donc les
flux les ficus avait que des trucs
dépêché voilà aussi mais après il ya eu
certains ont fait des photos ils sont
venus nous retrouver là et il y avait
certains qui étaient carrément devant là
sur la place de la torture oui la
fontaine torture fontaine tortue avec
l'escalier ti cats ou à la location
d'escalier celui ci était là ils ont pas
sur place et dans le dialogue parce
qu'on a fait un diaporama des artistes
qui étaient là et dans le diaporama on
voit bien on voit justement les artistes
en situation cesser dans l'exposition
aussi puisque le diaporama passera en
même temps que l'expo et on les voit on
dans les endroits comme ça et où il
n'était pas seulement à cet endroit là
parce qu'on a essayé de se répandre de
tout le long de la rivière 5e bien les
pierres parce que bien ceci est bien
cela il a fait deux tables rondes avec
deux bières différentes local local et
une pas local il a fait deux tableaux à
s'inquiéter face à la délivrance aussi
il était en bas et dans son tableau on
voit un morceau de lusine ne bien
justement et d aya il ya la délivrance
l'église de la délivrance corps buggé et
fabrice vous connaissez le baril
personne n'est pas du tout moi je suis
de sentir toucher bien vous connaissez
pas fabrice kamion au collège d'accord
ok alors géré moi je regrettais de ne
pas avoir vu par exemple la colline
saint denis ma moto bon maintenant je
comprends pourquoi puisque vous était
situé physiquement à l'embouchure
parce que c'est un endroit qui n'est pas
vraiment connu des gens même des
dionisio là bas mais nous on connaissait
pas vous êtes déjà là vous ne savez
lorsque vous traversez l'edf c'est au
bout de terre vous y allez un petit peu
j'étais là la petite voiture peut passer
en refermant d
les rétroviseurs vous à vous avez une
chapelle malbar en face aux prenez à
gauche vous continuez vous arrêter et
puis vous avez les gens qui habitent là
ils sont au calme sous la colline ya
personne pour les embêter c'est hyper
temps on est en pleine ville et on n'a
pas un bruit
d'abord je crois vous serez là bas la
belgique et arrivé jusqu'aux points
quand je suis arrivé je regardais gila
je passerai pas là je crois et puis je
vois un 4 4 qui traverse dans l'autre
sens il arrive du bon mais il a du
courage moi non bon c'est vous avoir
rappelé
rappelez-nous donc l'exploit des lieux
ou alors l'exposition a lieu dans
l'ancien hôtel de ville de saint-denis
au premier étage la salle d'exposition
est là elle est ouverte à partir de
demain jusqu'au 28 avril pendant les
heures d'ouverture de la mairie bien sûr
d'accord à l'intérieur mais merci en
tous les cas sa venue je voulais juste
rajouter un truc c'est à dire que si on
veut nous rejoindre
vu sur internet on a des problèmes
justement pour nous rejoindre la page
facebook du dard eu d'arrêt ouverte vous
pouvez nous contacter par là les numéros
dessus il ya eu daru d'art d'accord il y
aura donc vous passer un message par
facebook comme ça et on nous rejoignent
et merci d'être venus je suis pas que
sabine tyrrell merci aux dada merci aux
petits dada d'être venir
merci à vincent korvac de celle ci
jusqu'à saint pierre
donc on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
merci d'avoir écouté donc culture
première ça c'est pour vous sabine
terral
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
plus
non
[Musique]
quand la rivière
hélas bonheur et les fait l'amour avec
104 en arriver là
[Musique]
on les donne à gaza
m